a maggio
benissimo così facciamo una super sale e
cioè per 24 ore dovrebbe mutare solo
certi giganti anche i gatti giganti mata
sarà un momento di passaggio a rocco
giocattoli giganti come giocattoli di un
tacco di giocattoli giganti non vediamo
l'ora di giocarti io abbiamo una palla
gigante fair merlino che la romperà i
tre secondi che berlino questi
giocattoli giganti da stati un bel mi
piace per vedere altre challenge 24 ore
e guardate il video fino alla fine
perché dovrete votare quale il
giocattolo gigante che vi è piaciuto più
di tutti ma prima importante che cosa
sta facendo berlino secondo voi questo
momento
tanto ormai non sono sicuro che appena
vedrà tutti ipotizzo che la minaccia era
infatti rai si sveglierà e te devi
comodi prende di pop corn e patatine
siamo su minori sa che allora il primo
giocato l'oggetto è una bolla gigante a
chi è arrivato allora praticamente lui
si mette così rimane immobile perché sa
che io lo aiuto a salire in viaggio le
gambine o come reagirà alla bolla
gigante ho paura che la distruggerà
subito quindi dobbiamo stare attenti ai
tre interessantissimi sarà anche verde e
rossa vediamo subito come berlino è già
interessatissimo a
minuto allora ok è meglio se si sposta
sul tavolo perché berlino ha rubato
conti stranissima pubblicamente ti
permetti stop a berlino lasciamo in pace
bottino
[Musica]
dobbiamo stare attenti perché staccate
si potrebbe invocare quindi dobbiamo
stare sempre attentissimo
ecco come reagisce catania mirino anche
negli sembra vero esercito preferito le
forme che regala bonario fanno
rimbalzare per terra quanti ne mancata
un pò pc cosa ma è troppo bella continua
perché se non giocare ma sempre vuoi
provare sì eccoci qua siamo usciti fuori
per giocare un po con la nostra palla
gigante
adesso che berlino la bocca alla ribalta
il felicissimo
la bucata ecco qua è durato a tipo dieci
minuti quando balla
quindi siccome la giocata direi di farsi
giocare per lì non volgare vediamo come
si diverte
guardate guardate lo sforzo che ha fatto
per me importante che si sia divertito
secondo gioco gigante la fiducia che
voto diamo al primo gioco
io gli do un 8 perché è super divertente
berlino non l'ho mai visto così felice
voglio principale oggi per ogni lotto
perché si distrugge molto facilmente
dura poco diamo non va bene per giocarsi
con il cagnolone però abbiamo il secondo
gioco che sono dei lettori
ma andiamo subito ad aprirla francione
suddette di legnano l'altro ma che c'è
dentro in realtà si possono mettere gli
altri pezzi di lego ma noi non ce le
abbiamo
siamo solo i mezzi dei giganti e poi
oggi dobbiamo fare i giganti vediamo
berlina come reagirà te nun c'ho na
rossonero che scarica bellissimi
acciacco la torre di pisa a caso sarebbe
la torre di pisa sbarrate le zona che ha
bevuto l'acqua fresca caduti tutti fuori
bagnati e core che mancato così tanto
incorrendo la molla adesso è
stanchissimo ma berlino quella di
quotazione per i rialzi è troppo stanco
per capire il volo che sta succedendo
allora io mi metto qua il gioco vediamo
se lui arriva che carino pensa si apre
d'acqua
questo mi ricorda tipo la faccia del
brasile dobbiamo definirsi una faccina
tipo di dirti che l'ho fatto perché
berlino ad ora la frutta quindi ogni
volta che ti portano di già allora 8
arancione pensa che sia frutto
allora cari mirko messo molto
interessato
allora cosa potremo costruire anche se
la torre di pisa bisognava farlo però
così ti piace berlino frammenti futuro
costruito beccate questo erano poi
distruggere e non ne sono stato certo
come fino allora mettiamo anche in
questo modo sta accadendo
berlino avrò anche lui può costruire
qualcosa diciamo costruire lui vuole
distruggere di mantenermi macchia
rapporto è morto il 20 maggio quando ok
anche questo gioco per lì non si mangia
ma quello bianco
[Musica]
[Risate]
puoi giocare da berlino si aprono non si
che non riesce però a sapere che tuo
petto destro stato preferito mista a
questo giallo perché pensa che sia una
banana fortuna abbiamo tutto quello che
possiamo far detto non ci stanno dando
berlino aprirli allora ti faccio vedere
berlino che dentro non c'è niente guarda
il preferito di berlino è quello blu
decisamente quello blu allora meglio
questi nostri balzo lo si fanno le
costruzioni guarda
perché mi distrugge tutto per vivo
perché ero distrutto guarda che pensi
allora questo gioco secondo me molto
bello ma a berlino vuole distruggerlo lo
stesso poeta by questo gioco dobbiamo
nasconderlo perché merlino spazza
graffiato il tutto proprio si sta
divertendo carlino ok allora direi di
nascondere i lego è passare al prossimo
gioco altrimenti merlino steli mangerà
tutte frasi mitigati solo una matita il
gigante è un toro gigante a mio modo per
fare il brodo come dovremo giocare con
questi giochi qua per fortuna berlino
non li può distruggere forze che come
l'omaggio al nord a metà così anche la
matita chiedo un floor feat
sarà una volta testa disegneremo
qualcosa con una matita gigante quindi è
più difficile è già lontano perché hanno
visto le altre falle sardegna e poi il
dado deciderà che punti abbiamo verdi
segno solo per il plesso con berlino
tutta chisari una matita rivedremo che
iniziò in volta fatti punti fidanzato
siamo pronti almeno proprio allora prima
di te
consegnare berlino berlino inizio
vediamo se c'è niente non so nemmeno se
funziona bastava vita vediamo non so
come la posso ottenere così ho cosi ajaj
la verde perché io ti piace che questo
cretino o no diteci che non c'è tutto
berlino la bella mora di cancello ti
cancello ottica cielo di cancello non
funziona da berlino guarda che bel
ritratto che ti porta all'esordio
sociali non cancellabile facciamo un po
[Musica]
addio è un po scomodo allora è un bel po
scomodo disegnare tra il nasino addio al
cielo bruttissimo po di sfumature
attorno agli occhi perché berlino si è
truccato berlina sentita media no io no
no tav i danni danni ma insomma
furbacchione allora sembra un po
malefico come l'ho disegnato le orecchie
le facciamo
berlino stima già latita ha detto ma
allora berlino sta cercando vuoi provare
a disegnare to vediamo vediamo come ti
senti in via o stai con la passata meno
male ha capito che non era molto buona
da rosicchiare oddio mi uscito volto
vale berlino porte che ha uno sguardo
magnetico qua come poi andare chi un po
più scure claro mamma o la vita non è un
dovermi ok allora questa challenge
finisce qua perché parlino ha deciso di
prendersi la motilità ladro vi è l'idea
lui caspit frattempo che sta facendo
berlino cosa ho fatto mi andavo berlino
anzi li metto in bocca qualcosa perché
queste ore sgranocchiando qualcosa
quindi questa è la matita è arrivato
merlino allora eccolo qua a berlino si è
un po calmato anche un po stanco
altrimenti sarebbe ancora visitato
brutto piazza e animo ha prezzo secondo
me il bambino non ho apprezzato di
offendere preferisce prendeva dire
quando sono il bisogno puoi provare a
disegnare il tuo berlino
vediamo se adesso cancellare con questa
compagni kant e berlino abbiamo guardato
quanto mi dà per questo disegno orribile
di merlino ho sentito e letto
ovviamente berlino è andato a prendere
il dato da sotto il letto per mare siamo
riusciti a salvarlo in tempo
allora cerco di tirarmi quadro va bene
ora tocca abitante di amarli non
concordano il risultato per quattro
perché il disegno bellino ma io ho
cercato di fatica adesso tocca a te
vediamo un po come ts merlino sono
proprio curiosa bene poi chiamarsi lei
ma facendo ma questo arresto matitone
dai ma allora possiamo averli dato
piegati seggio dalle orecchiette un po
troppi pistrella e poi lui è pipistrello
numerica che un pipistrello nel aspetta
questo il nasone che lo dobbiamo fare di
tutto nero nero nero
loiero nieri che si facevano l'effetto
3d delle narici e praticamente quali
dobbiamo fare e questa è la boccuccia
perché questa è la lingua di sotto
questi sono i puntoni dei baffetti giro
marino ed forno cacciati veletti poi gli
facciamo gli occhi piccoli paura le
ombreggiature sotto gli occhi sono gli
occhi dove si chiama centro chiaia
sterline per tiene all esatto è finito
il corpo così
tenere a bellino così vediamo come se
vende no ma che si aspetta che dobbiamo
fare la codeina dietro la codeina
società dietro
se invece la codeina paura allora
vediamo differenze ha detto allora lui
aspetta sempre che io li tiri sulle
zampe per farlo saliti ora prima tiriamo
il dato vediamo quanti così descritto
nei dati di me e poi vediamo il marito
come regis vai o no ma secondo voi usare
quelle più bello per lo meno lo sapevo
[Applauso]
ma dai che ti fa male questo è mio
marito mi sembra dice caro birds è
rimasto scioccato dalla sua bellezza
guarda un po marino un relitto è questo
sei tu hai visto che bello sei proprio
tu vero c'è rimasto male sguardo di
marmo bianco rete 4 è cambiato
fermare edi rama veramente periti che tu
racconti brugger tu sei tu dove non è
ancora finito su quello colore coraggio
bello tema del vice l'ideale per me non
c'è rimasto male vero
parole perché ha detto nessuno dei miei
quadroni mi riesce a disegnare bene
vedrete come si è arrabbiato perché la
spesa è arrivato il momento di giocare
al prossimo gioco gigante il prossimo
gioco gigante per una le carte ci
vediamo ti ascolto marini e proverà
berline berlino proverà a distruggerle
non penso anche queste le forme
consolidato per scriverli notare pensare
tutto trovano vantare berlino giochiamo
può poker di reti che bello
vediamo un po per non mischiare queste
carte sono usate per fare come gestirli
e mi piaceva tanto vale materiali gioco
di carte proveremo a fare il castello di
carte con le carte giganti l'accordo ha
stabilito che non vi garello l'unico
pezzo che ho fatto benissimo ma devono
stare attaccate nome ragazzi
[Musica]
ok poi questo fra aspetta che siano sto
ancora facendo 12 sopra ora arriva a
berlino e fa cadere il frutto speriamo
che riusciamo con grande gusto pastello
nome di più forse adesso la mettiamo
vediamo chi lo farà cadere bellissime
queste carte la ragione non sta
continuando a portarmi il nostro per
tirarglielo nostro di gomma cosa
è tutto sotto controllo se non ci sei tu
non mi sembra possibile brano da questo
cartello per lione milan fermo non
povere niente berlino berlino stai fermo
tmw sbattuto sul tavolo piedi per l'inno
visto molto più delle scarpe tua
purtroppo forte passa passa le carte ma
se la cava ma c è un succede niente bene
dobbiamo cercare di ballo più alto
possibile
mangia berlino che posso siamo a questo
gioco ma non abbiamo dato il voto e
leggo allora che doniamo
oltre mezzo minuto e mezzo perché
pensavo che ce n'erano più di pezzi
dentro vi erano nascosti
fantastiche per aspettare che succeda e
piacevoli fresco berlino ventilatori e
invece che voto diamo le carte si gatti
sì perché perché sono molto mosso non
riesco a fare i castelli io adoro fare
ricascati di gas
io e mi dava un atto perché se che è
durato tutto per dire che mi faceva
giocare a carte che dalle casse
giustizia cambi nascondere
all'avversario le carte ai se si parla
di combustibile rimasto molto
affascinato dal km
le carte allora andiamo a prendere
l'ultimo già pronti a meno
ecco l'ultimo gioco gigante e voi direte
ma che cos'è questo limone rinsecchito
nuovo in realtà è una palla come quelle
da tennis ma gigante immaginate berlino
conto infatti a tono una palla da tennis
gigante non vediamo l'ora di vedere la
sua reazione più questa è un po più
robusta si spera quindi non dovrebbe
distruggersi subito forte impiegherà un
minuto prima del commerce vediamo
torniamo a gonfiare l'artista allora il
bug è tutto qui
io fiduciosi dotti fermo non mi morte hi
hi hi hi
[Risate]
si no anche sopra è un po pelosa proprio
come le palline da te la diamo a
parlarle ma mi sa che berlino volete una
palla perfetta e proprio strani perché
faceva rumore non ora andiamo a giocare
fuori controllo
indovinate vi commenti quanto durerà
questa palla di berlino
[Musica]
miranda non è una palla la barbie bella
del mondo
[Musica]
non abboccare mirino
che dite gliela facciamo prendere un
pochino sì o la paura che una volta che
mi apprenderà durerà tre secondi perché
la morderà tutta la bucherà vediamo
proviamo a fargliela prendere da solo e
poi vediamo quanto dura prendiamo salta
salta mi prendi la tv la vediamo chi
riesce a prenderlo prima ovviamente che
sia la prima berlina è troppo grande per
lui non riesce a morderla perché troppo
grandi per niente al mondo la palla era
ancora viva questa palla è ancora vivo
incredibile nostro polo sud
non posso credere ma se riusciamo anche
a conservarla
a parte durerà mezza giornata allora
ecco che la sta rosicchiando forse è
arrivato il momento della morte per
quella palla che cosa facciamo
glielo lasciamo ancora con la togliamo
ragazze incredibile è sopravvissuta ha
scoperto che nessuno aveva indovinato
che sarebbe sopravvissuto perché io non
avrei mai scommesso berlina allora
abbiamo deciso di non lasciar gliela
sempre altrimenti la distruzione ben di
sicuro ma la conserviamo e ogni volta
che vogliamo giocare assieme
gliela diamo anche noi è strafelice
chissà quanto tempo durerà magari non
era un po di più la settimana penso che
questo sia il gioco preferito di berlino
fino all'uomo kabul
allora abbondate il quale gioco vi piace
di più tra tutti i giochi giganti
potete anche votare la polpa wall che si
è rotta purtroppo ha fatto una brutta
fine
ma votate quale vi piace di più dei
commenti
mi piace per vedere altre challenge 24
ore pazzesche come questa amici nei
commenti qual è il momento che vi ha
divertito sprigionatesi minuto costino
ieri
per provare i nostri altri video
c'è da scoprire
no
[Musica]